[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti grazie per questo
invito a 3 dec swim è veramente una cosa
interessante essere qui e poter
condividere con voi quella che è
l'esperienza del terzo settore e
l'innovazione del terzo settore anche
credo che sia molto importante far
vedere come questo terzo settore che già
di per sé il nome da un po un'idea di
qualcosa che deve arrampicarsi per
arrivare al primo posto possa essere
invece un portatore di innovazione di
idee e di anche di suggestioni
importantissime ma anche di passioni
perché quello che noi dobbiamo
trasmettere è l'innovazione e la
tecnologia al servizio dell'uomo e della
passione
io volevo cominciare questo mio piccolo
racconto di esperienza di 40 anni di
vita
io forse un po di più ma l'ho vissuta
l'ho vissuta per chelante è stata
fondata qua a bologna nel 1978 ma da mio
padre ma poi è cresciuta e ha trasferito
l'idea delle odiosi a della dignità
della vita anche in giro per il mondo e
questa è una cosa bella perché questo
significa che i valori i valori veri
sono quelli che si possono condividere
che possono veramente accumulare l'uomo
e la sua vita
ecco quindi che alla base comunque della
idea e delle passioni ci deve essere un
metodo perché questo metodo può portare
a nuove idee ea nuove scoperte ed è la
cosa più importante perché è il terzo
settore con i bisogni della società
perché il terzo settore nasce perché ci
sono dei bisogni inespressi da parte del
pubblico perché ci sono delle belle dei
bisogni che il pubblico non riesce a
coglierla allora in questo senso già di
per sé molti degli enti del terzo
settore rappresentano l'innovazione
l'innovazione di metodo l'innovazione di
processo l'innovazione di tecnologie ma
quello che io vi voglio raccontare oggi
è proprio un innovazione di processo e
di mentalità e in questo senso è il
terzo settore veramente un innovazione
io credo che il terzo settore deve
funzionare anche da collante tra quelli
che sono i diversi mondi della società e
quindi il mondo economico e non
del mondo il profit il mondo pubblico in
mezzo c'è questo c'è questo terzo
settore che deve fare da matching tra
leader tra le diverse realtà deve essere
un soggetto attivo della società
non possiamo pensare che il terzo
settore sia soltanto quello che chiede
dei fondi il terzo settore è quello che
veramente riesce a far collaborare tutti
ad un unico processo e questa è la cosa
importante è la cosa significativa e
l'innovazione dell'idea del terzo
settore
io vi raccontavo prima che nel 1978
qui a bologna nella nostra città è nata
l'ump e in questo senso l'arte è voluta
è nata con l'idea di mettersi in ascolto
a quelli che sono i bisogni delle
persone ha pensato che l'uomo deve
essere al centro della nostra della
nostra idee delle nostre attività e
quindi condividere le sue passioni
intesa come sofferenza intesa come
bisogno di aiuto se ci pensate bene
la solidarietà è la risposta al richiamo
della sofferenza questo è l'idea di
solidarietà che accomuna l'uomo e
accomuna anche naturalmente il terzo
settore ma ci deve essere un metodo
dietro come dicevo nata nel 78 ma c'è
stata una rivoluzione copernicana anche
in questo senso una innovazione
in che senso nel momento in cui l'anta
ha deciso di portare a casa
l'ospedale quando nel 1978 il primario
della divisione del sant'orsola malpigli
che aveva molti letti a disposizione per
cui poteva curare le persone disse ai
suoi capi a quelli che erano i dirigenti
dell'asl e quindi il pubblico disse io
voglio portare l'ospedale a domicilio
questi lo guardarono in sera professore
a tanti posti letto le persone sicuro
nell'ospedale li abbiamo costruiti
apposta e lui andò avanti per la sua
strada
perché anche questo è dirompente avere
la capacità di vedere lontano avere la
capacità di cogliere quelle che sono
degli aspetti che la gente non riesce a
cogliere e quindi la rivoluzione
copernicana
l'ospedale che va a casa delle persone
ecco in questo momento da bologna questo
ospedale che va a casa delle persone è
andato in tutta italia
l'ant è andata anche in europa perché
collaboriamo con progetti europei
portiamo la nostra esperienza nella
nostra europa l'europa che ha creato un
sistema sanitario che deve essere un
diritto per le persone ma questo diritto
deve poter essere esercitato
ecco quindi che ci vuole un metodo un
modo un modello che permetta di essere
sostenibile nel tempo nello spazio e nel
tempo ecco quindi l'ant che è riuscita a
replicare un modello nato a bologna in
tante altre parti d'italia
ecco quindi land che da quel paziente
assistito da quei sette pazienti
assistiti nel primo anno
oggi ha curato e ha portato assistenza a
oltre 127mila sofferenti di tumore in
modo completamente gratuito
ma l'alta non si è fermata qui allora
abbiamo pensato una cosa che cosa
possono servire le nuove tecnologie cosa
significa per noi o per innovation nuove
tecnologie
beh significa metterla a disposizione
dell'uomo vedete quella signora è una
nostra paziente è una persona che aveva
bisogno di aiuto
e allora i medici allora gli infermieri
ma allora anche le nuove tecnologie
ecco quindi che nel 2016 è nata l'idea
di questa realtà virtuale che potesse
trasportare quel paziente che stava a
casa fuori dalla propria casa un'altra
rivoluzione che potesse aiutarli a
gestire al meglio quello che era il
dolore quella che era la solitudine che
si trovava a vivere
ecco quindi che per noi open innovation
che per noi nuove tecnologie significa
la possibilità di stare vicino sempre di
più e sempre meglio alle persone poi nel
2018 abbiamo voluto dire un'altra cosa
abbiamo voluto dire che ant non era solo
lì per fare quello per cui era nata 40
anni fa ma ci siamo posti un problema
che cosa dobbiamo fare
se adesso le linee guida della sanità
parlano tutte di assistenza domiciliare
che parlano tutti di gestione a casa del
paziente cronico è finita la nostra
ricerca di innovazione è finito nel
nostro scopo
no non è finito quello che noi volevamo
fare è trovare e sollecitare ancora di
più e ancora meno il pubblico verso
nuove idee e allora è nato a questo
sprint foray dias che cos'è spring for
aids quella di mettere in comunicazione
aziende che potessero avere del capitale
con nuove idee con start up che
potessero sviluppare queste nuove queste
nuove idee al servizio della persona al
servizio del modello di assistenza
domiciliare
ecco quindi che sono arrivate 30 nuove
idee che noi abbiamo selezionato e che
potranno essere finanziate grazie a
questo progetto innovativo a questa idea
di open innovation che avevamo anche noi
questa idea di processo per cui
mettevamo noi anche
insieme e in comunicazione il mondo
economico con l'idea di start up per il
sofferente di tumore per portare aiuto
ai pazienti per quell idea di
condivisione e di ascolto di cui abbiamo
parlato prima perché in questo senso noi
rappresentiamo vogliamo essere soggetti
attivi nella società l'avevo detto
all'inizio lo porto adesso come esempio
beh spring for ideas è andata molto bene
abbiamo premiato un'azienda che
permetterà un suo progetto verrà
sviluppato a milano ea roma verranno
portati a casa e portati in ospedale
questi pazienti grazie a questo questa
nuova questa nuova piattaforma e queste
nuove persone che lavoreranno con anta
con l'idea di condividere delle
esperienze con l'idea di mettersi
insieme affinché si potesse migliorare
l'assistenza ai pazienti affinché si
potesse realizzare quell'idea di
eubiosia parola nuova parola che abbiamo
inventato noi eubiosia alla buona vita
la dignità della vita fino all'ultimo
momento ma ci sono ancora tante sfide
che si devono fare lante vi raccontavo
prima a molti pazienti 126 mila pazienti
10.000 pazienti assistiti ogni anno
dobbiamo raccogliere quelle che vengono
definite adesso i big data
dobbiamo cercare di trovare nuovi metodi
e nuova tecnologia affinché questi dati
non vengano dispersi perché perché
interessante raccogliere dati certo che
no perché è importante cercare di
personalizzare ancora di più ancora
meglio l'assistenza domiciliare
noi dobbiamo pensare che abbiamo come
obiettivo comune l'uomo dobbiamo pensare
che le nuove tecnologie i modelli
innovativi le scoperte che noi facciamo
debbano sempre avere come idea e come e
come obiettivo sia che stiamo parlando
di mondo profit sia che stiamo parlando
di mondo non profit sia che stiamo
parlando di nuove tecnologie o di
modelli assistenziali
l'uomo al centro l'idea della dignità
della vita l'eubiosia grazie
[Applauso]